[Applause]
you got
paula abdul brian austin green ashley
tisdale they will all try and guess who
is the masked
dancer debbie this premieres on fox next
month i mean
it looks like ken jong is going to be
pulling double duty the man's got jobs
yes he's getting checks meanwhile the
latest singer unmasked well he revealed
himself
to a full house
you're on the best singer your tv
daughter candace cameron bray guessed
like the very first week she sent you a
video oh my gosh
like the second note you hit i'm like
that's bob it's so cute
you celebrate each other's wins you
mourn each other's losses i remember you
even saying
you sent lori a text and told her you
loved her and you're thinking about her
when you care about somebody especially
now i'm finding
you got to let them know i put out my
love for
for lori everybody hurts when somebody
hurts it's nice to get that
heart emoji back okay so who from fuller
house would you
like to see on the mast singer and we
can't say john because
he already does it
i still want to see john okay he was
going to be a clue
the following week had i made it he's
very humble about his singing about it
he's so
good hello hello hello
he would be amazing especially if they
made him the most grotesque monster and
they take off
the head and you see the cutest thing
you ever saw in your package you talked
about how you use
laughter and comedy as a way to like
lift your spirits and lift you up
how has you know laughter and comedy
saved you majorly it's funny when
you know it automatically when you said
in your package
my mind goes to a different place you
know
my package has saved me a couple times i
can get away with it because i didn't
say anything
my family my eyelashes i'm sorry
you